[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
olivier comme ancien officier en
afghanistan ex-conseiller politique à
kaboul de l'ambassadeur européen bonsoir
olivier crown merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous à vos côtés régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france bonsoir régis le
sommier donc vous avez donc passé quatre
ans olivier kohn en afghanistan nous a
desservis comme militaire puis comme
diplomate vous connaissez donc très bien
effectivement le terrain mais aussi
l'aspect plus diplomatique quand on voit
ce message un petit peu voilà ce libye
l'un des américains qui n'osent pas trop
reprocher clairement se dit quoi on n'a
pas le choix on essaye de garder la
farce
savez quelque qu'est ce que peut faire
les américains concrètement je veux dire
là il faut il faut il
faut comprendre la situation la guerre
est perdue il faut l'admettre c'est
c'est un fait donc les aveugles et les
américains ont quitté le territoire
afghan s'est terminée la guerre est
finie donc il ne reste plus grand chose
à faire sinon des cylons d'évacuer les
tous les afghans qui la coalition a
travaillé ce que fait la france par
ailleurs également quoi donc le constat
effectivement est difficile mais que
faire d'autre
effectivement que faire d'autre régis le
sommier les américains qui se disent
préoccupés voilà le mot est un petit peu
bizarrement choisi mais attendent de
voir de voir quoi c'est un échec
clairement alors cette nomination de ce
gouvernement dit
intérimaire donc on verra comment les
choses vont se sa fille mais il y aura
peut-être d'autres personnalités et
d'autres noms qui vont poindre c'est
quand même globalement une gifle à la
flamme à la face de la mairie qu'il faut
le reconnaître dans ce gouvernement
figurent ping comme chef du gouvernement
quelqu'un qui a eu dont le fils est mort
dans un attentat suicide comme kamikazes
vous avez donc sirajuddin haqqani qui
étaient directement sur une liste
américaine y avait une rivière et
comment à une demande de rançon de 10
millions de dollars sur sa tête parce
qu'il a été comment identifier comme
responsable d'un des pires attentats qui
a été commis à kaboul contre l'inter
continental il ya eu un peu plus de 100
morts une véritable attaque de cet hôtel
international donc voilà dans le
gouvernement figurent des aussi quatre
anciens de guantanamo qui ont du sang
sur les mains clairement le message que
les talibans ont voulu faire passer
c'est d'abord un message en interne
c'est d'abord un message de dire quand
on dit gouvernement inclusif il est
inclusif à la talibane c'est à dire ça
inclut toutes les parties du mouvement
les durs donc un cas ni et puis les un
peu plus modérées baradar encore que
baradar comme j'ai dis déjà ici ne doit
son nom ont directement au mollah omar
ça veut dire frères mollah omar
l'appeler frères dont vous avez le
mollah akoun et le mollah baradar
les deux exécutifs du du gouvernement
qui sont directement liés au mollah omar
donc à l'équipe précédente acuna d'ascq
et le guide spirituel également mais
était en charge de la vie de
l'administration de la charia dans la
précédente équipe on se souvient de la
duty 2 comment et la sauvagerie dont
avait fait preuve les talibans à
l'époque pour l'application de la loi
coranique donc on peut se dire que
clairement on a non seulement une équipe
qui est très dur mais on a aussi des
gens qui ont été en contact avec ben
laden à l'époque qui ont probablement
assister à ce qu'on a appelé la bahia
c'est à dire là comment le serment
d'allégeance d'al qaïda aux talibans au
mollah omar en personne pour la voix les
avoir accueillis en afghanistan les
liens on sait entre les talibans et al
qaïda
jamais été complètement comment
ce serment 7 bahia elle a été renouvelée
au fil des ans donc on se rend compte
que là dessus il ya des choses qui sont
quand même très inquiétante même d'un
point de vue américain même si on peut
dire que les américains attendent sans
doute que les talibans montrent
peut-être une forme d'ouverture grâce
certainement pas de femmes à mon sens
mais peut-être quelques figures de
l'opposition qui viendraient un peu à
comment envoyer un message à la
communauté internationale parce que les
talibans vont avoir besoin d'argent ils
vont avoir besoin de soutien économique
les chinois on l'a dit son sont déjà
dans la place mais ça ne suffira
peut-être pas en tout cas anthony avec
anin pour pour finir sur ce rôle analyse
de ces réactions parce qu'elles sont
effectivement intéressante elle cache
beaucoup de d'arrière pensées bien
évidemment anthony blinken est arrivé en
allemagne avec l'espoir d'avoir une
réponse un petit peu coordonnée sur la
nomination de ce gouvernement c'est raté
la france est clairement plus clair les
exigences de la communauté
internationale ne sont pas remplies
l'union européenne 1 déplore de son côté
ce gouvernement on l'a dit me inclusif
ni représentatif comment vous l'analysez
olive et kroon ce différence de son de
cloche et ne pas avoir fédéré finalement
pour anthony blinken
ben disons que le son de cloche qui
n'est pas si différent ça en réalité
parce que la déclaration de l'union
européenne l'a dernièrement ça a été une
sorte de déception un peu officiel de
devant ce gouvernement taleb quoi to
resist viens de décrire je pense qu'il
faut ni il faut se faire strictement
aucune illusion à dire les talibans
nouvelle version vingt ans après non non
pas changé sur le fond la substance est
la même ils se sont modernisées il faut
dix ont des comptes twitter etc mais le
fond c'est le même le programme c'est le
même maintenant ça faisait vingt ans
qu'ils étaient ceux qui combattaient
pour reprendre le pouvoir parce qu'à
l'époque entre 96 et 2001 il avait il
était à kaboul mais il contrôlait pas
tout l'afghanistan contre les pâtes ou
l'afghanistan et dumont il leur manquait
le dernier tiers la ligne de front
coin ça va passer par le panchir qui
vient de tomber donc je veux dire il ya
sur le fond il n'y a rien à changer
tout ça pour ça des milliards après
désarmement qui se retrouve maintenant
aux mains des talibans c'est peut-être
ça le grand changement ça veut dire le
point zéro pour vous réellement tout ça
pour ça évidemment c'est une question
qu'on se pose tous sauf un quiconque a
servi ou est passé en afghanistan
damman se pose forcément cette question
là tout ça pour ça mais on peut jamais
le savoir peut jamais savoir comment la
faire se termine donc si vous voulez il
ya un constat c'est que
la partie est perdue ça ne veut pas dire
que sur les vingt ans d'engagement de la
coalition là bas il ne restera rien il
ya eu des infrastructures qui ont été
bâties construit il ya eu des toute une
génération qui a été scolarisé malgré
tout il en restera quelque chose même si
l'élite est en train de partir de
quitter le pays en fin c'est de cesser
la session
plénière
absolument mais enfin bon il restera
toujours quelque chose
voilà bon même si même si l'afer est
perdu maintenant la gueule la question
effectivement c'est comment
l'afghanistan des talibans avec un
gouvernement taliban qui est aliments au
pouvoir comment vont-ils s'en sortir
parce que le pays était sous perfusion
économique pendant 20 ans par par la
communauté internationale
tout ça c'est fini je veux dire les
robinets sont finis tout les flux sans
couper il reste certainement des acteurs
régionaux régis l'un d'eux cité la chine
qui a probablement pour enfin seraient
potentiellement on va dire pourrait
potentiellement être un acteur qui
prendrait entre guillemets la relève et
encore et encore justement c'est
intéressant parce que la réaction de la
chine et pour le coup très dissonante
elle clairement je vous propose de
l'écouter avant d'en parler
la chine attache une grande importance à
l'annonce par les talibans de la mise en
place d'un gouvernement provisoire et de
certains arrangements importants
concernant le personnel cela a mis fin à
plus de trois semaines d'un archet en
afghanistan et constitue une étape
nécessaire pour rétablir l'ordre et
reconstruire le pays
nous avons également noté que les
taliban ont déclaré que le gouvernement
intérimaire devait rétablir l'ordre
social et économique le plus rapidement
possible
réaction
chinois et pour le coup l'arrière pensée
tout à fait les chinois ne raisonne pas
du tout comme nous il faut prendre ça en
considération il ne voit pas du tout la
thalie le l'afghanistan comme un pays ou
une entité avec un gouvernement il le
voit comme une voie de passage comme une
voie de passage qui fait partie de leurs
faveurs projet de route de la soie il y
en a même plusieurs noms en tout cas ils
pensent l'aghanistan exactement comme
les grands conquérants ont pensé c'est à
dire comme un chemin comme un chemin
qu'on veut contrôler comme une zone
qu'on veut contrôler mais pas tellement
comme un pays en réalité donc ce qu il
en rapporte aujourd'hui c'est là ce qui
est le propos de ce ministre chinois est
important c'est l'idée de la stabilité
et de l'ordre est ce que les chinois he
on rappelle on dans le dans leurs dents
dans l'ouest du pays une certaine
population musulmane assez importantes
dont ont émergé d'ailleurs des
mouvements jihadistes
parmi les ouigours qui a dix qui se sont
d'ailleurs répandue à travers le monde
on en trouve jusqu'en syrie et est donc
ils n'ont pas du tout envie que
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'un émirat
islamique
avec des taliban à leurs frontières je
rappelle qu'il ya 90 km de frontière
entre la chine et l'afghanistan se
concrétise par am zone d'instabilité
chez eux c'est aussi le cas des russes
pour tout l'or leur sphère d'influencé
avec les anciennes républiques
soviétiques musulmane donc l'ouzbékistan
le tadjikistan le kirghizstan qui sont
juste au nord personne n'a envie de voir
déborder une forme d'instabilité ou de
voir un effet talibans dans son pays
donc le retour à l'ordre est primordial
pour les chinois et puis évidemment
après cela s'accompagnera t-il d'une
aide économique ça ça reste à voir vous
l'avez assez justement dit parce qu'à
chaque fois comme pour la reconstruction
de la syrie et chinois arrivent et
disent on est là on est là on est là et
puis ça attend ça à temps et il y a
beaucoup de conditions avant que les
chinois agissent mais cela dit sur les
plats question talibane il avait pris
langue avec le mouvement bien avant son
arrivée au pouvoir
à kaboul le 15 août dernier et il y
avait déjà eu le ministre des affaires
étrangères chinois qui s'était affichée
donc là il ya une sorte de pragmatisme
absolue giret et - d'atermoiements sur
qui est dans le gouvernement ce qui est
ce que semble au contraire craindre la
plupart des pays occidentaux
alors quel avenir maintenant vous avez
commencé à nous en parlait tout à
l'heure pour vous pas beaucoup de
changement c'est la vie d'une femme elle
s'appelle faouzia confie l été
figurez-vous ancien député donc au
parlement avant puisque vous m'aviez dit
lo'jo il y avait bien des femmes au
parlement elle ait pas effectivement et
je vous propose justement d'écouté sur
son analyse
par rapport à leur premier règne ils
veulent faire croire qu'ils ont changé
mais ce changement n'existe qu'au niveau
de leurs dirigeants politiques eux ont
voyagé à l'étranger en russie en turquie
en chine au kazakhstan et au qatar en
réalité les combattants et les
commandants talibans qui ne connaissent
que la guerre et les armes ne peuvent
accepter les changements de la société
afghane
olivier c'est intéressant ce qu'elle
soulève cette ancienne députée afghane
clairement il ya une différence notable
entre le combattant du terrain
et certainement croiser souvent et le
dirigeant qui s'est émancipé mais en
tout cas qui a qui a voyagé qui a les
codes des occidentaux
les codes des occidentaux c'est un bien
grand oui je m'en vais peut-être un
petit pas mais en tout cas mais
effectivement non il ya une élite
talibane si on peut parler si on
pourrait les appeler tristement comme ça
mais effectivement ce sont des gens qui
pour partie était réfugié enfin se
cacher au pakistan voilà il ya obtient
une différence on inventa effectivement
entre les vieux cadres enfin qui eux
mêmes ont fait du terrain parce que la
plupart melli régissent tout à l'heure
c'est ce sont des gars qui ont mouillé
le maillot quand combattu à une autre
époque à 20 ans ont maintenant ils sont
aux commandes donc une partie
effectivement se cacher au pakistan
parce qu'ils étaient ciblés par par la
coalition par les américains ensuite il
y en a quelques-uns d'entre eux qui ont
été engagées dans des moments dans l'est
dans les discussions diplomatiques à
doha donc c'est effectivement il y en a
un petit groupe
parmi eux qui en pions comme vous venez
de citer la députée convoyage est qu'ils
sont allés motion ou à doha et c'est
maintenant le effectivement il ya une
différence entre eux et le conte et le
combattant taleb qui lui est un mystique
qui est
capable grande ouverture d'esprit ça
reste quand même voilà un combattant de
base qui a fait vingt ans de guerre va
tenter un je veux dire lui lui il y
débarque à kaboul ou ailleurs d'ailleurs
faut pas s'attendre
grande tolérance de leur part ça c'est
certain effectivement
les députés eux mêmes c'est avec la
constitution afghane prévoyait
un quota de 20 % de députées qui doit
être des femmes quoi donc il y avait un
important du parlement afghan qui était
composé de deux femmes je pense que ce
temps là est révolu et bien terminer et
j ce qui est intéressant pour poursuivre
c'est que même à certains moments de des
négociations de doha qui ont duré
plusieurs années il ya eu parfois des
dissensions entre le groupe présent à
doha et les combattants sur le terrain
qu'ils disaient pendant que vous
bavarder nous on fait la guerre on
pratique une forme d'austérité vous
vivez luxueusement dans des dangers des
hôtels il ya eu dans le mouvement
taliban des critiques justement sur ces
négociations de la part du terrain et la
part des militaires sur le terrain des
durs du mouvement notamment vis-à-vis de
ses négociations avec les américains je
rajouterais une précision là dessus à
l'époque des généraux que vous avez
connu régis qui ont été nos grands chefs
de la coalition où je rappelle qu'on
était quand même 150 mille hommes sur le
terrain au plus fort de la guerre des
généraux comme mcchrystal ou petraeus
qui sont quand même des grandes figures
militaire une des semaines de leur
stratégie à l'époque c'était de deux
cibles et de décapiter soul et les
commandants terrain nos terrains je
précise bien de terrain parce que les
grands chefs se cachait au pakistan
était très difficile de les cibler donc
ça a été une stratégie c'était
d'éliminer soul est l'équivalent des
lieutenants et de capitaines entre
guillemets pour faire une comparaison
avec une armée moderne et donc ça a été
ces gars-là énormément ramassé sur le
terrain voilà ils n'ont pas vécu la même
guerre que le chef qui est dès que le
chef taleb à keita ou à peshawar les
deux choix par ailleurs la à l'époque un
mois des dissensions au sein du
mouvement taliban mais voilà ces voix là
c'est pas tout à fait la même guerre
maintenant la farce et elle est pareil
jouer là ya pas de
fondamentalement une différence entre le
grand chef qui est allé à moscou à doha
etc et puis le taleb qui lui a fait
monter au carton sur le terrain quoi
c'est le programme n'est pas juste pour
conclure ce décryptage look avait
justement on le disait passé quatre ans
en tant qu'officier sur le terrain
peut-être un sentiment plus personnel
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est un
sentiment d'échec en afghanistan c'est
qu'est ce que vous ressentez c'est un
sentiment très difficile c'est un lourd
sentiment difficile et douloureux
séquence effectivement on reste sur un
échec on peut passer c'est un constat il
faut s'y faire c'est douloureux mais
c'est une réalité donc on se pose la
question tout ça pour ça mais on pouvait
pas le savoir au début et je pense moi
personnellement mais seulement la vie
personnelle que la cause était juste
quoi la cause était juste on est parti
là-bas après voilà on est ça a été un
engrenage puis ça s'est terminé
malheureusement comme ça mais voilà on
revient on rembobine pas là le film
c'est voilà la partie et de jouer ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que
le programme talent immense et est de
conquérir il y avait un programme des
oeuvres un réel programme politique
prendre le pouvoir à kaboul prendre
contrôler l'afghanistan et ils avaient
une stratégie militaire je pense que
nous avons sous-estimé
il y avait une réelle stratégie
militaire je pourrais citer les exemples
voilà qui sont peut-être un peu méconnu
mais mais voilà ils avaient ils étaient
déterminés ils ont fait vingt ans de
guerre et ils y sont arrivés voilà et si
vous voulez en face le constat
peut-être le plus douloureux de voir
l'armée afghanes auxquelles nous avons
participé à constituer à former enfin ça
a coûté des milliards ça coûte et enfin
en ressources est colossal qui ces
courageux courageusement battu un jour
je tiens à le préciser
alors ça s'est effondré sur la fin parce
que si vous voulez quand vous avez le
chef qui se barre en premier les normes
et ne continue pas de se battre sur le
terrain quand le chef se barre bon c'est
fini et le président afghan ashraf ghani
a été le premier à monter dans l'avion
il reflète le camp
c'est profond regret ce soir que mon
propre réplique se soit terminée sur une
tragédie similaire
merci à tous les deux en tout cas merci
d'avoir été là merci cg ce souvenir on
retrouvera évidemment pour nous dire
encore beaucoup de choses je vouvoyais
réagir merci à vous en tout cas tous les
deux